nos dan este polinomio px que es un
polinomio de tercer grado y nos dicen
gráfica todos los ceros intersección en
x del polinomio en la gráfica
interactiva y aunque dice gráfica
interactiva esta es una imagen de
pantalla del ejercicio en khan academy
donde pueden hacer clic y colocar los
puntos donde están los ceros lo
importante aquí es darnos cuenta de
cuáles son los valores de x que hacen
que p de x sea igual a 0 ya que esos
eran los ceros y después podemos
graficar los pausa en el vídeo y vean si
pueden resolverlo el punto clave aquí es
tratar de factorizar esta expresión de
aquí que es una expresión de tercer
grado queremos encontrar aquellos
valores de x que hacen que 5 x a la
tercera más 5 x cuadrada menos 30 x sea
igual a 0 la forma en la que hacemos
esto es factor izando el lado izquierdo
de esta expresión lo primero que busco
es un factor común a todos estos
términos y parece que todos los términos
pueden dividirse entre 5x
esto es 5 x x quitamos 5 x 5 x a la
tercera lo que nos da x cuadrada
quitamos 5 x a 5 x cuadrada y nos queda
x y finalmente quitamos 5 x a menos 30 x
lo que da menos 6 todo esto igual a 0 y
ahora tenemos 5 x que multiplica esta
expresión de segundo grado y para
factorizar aún más pensemos en que par
de números al sumar se dan 1 podemos ver
esto como 1 x y su producto es menos 6
veamos pues 3 negativo y 2 positivo
pueden ser reescribimos esto como 5x por
x + 3 por x 2 y si lo que acabo de hacer
no les parece familiar los invito a que
revisen la factorización de cuadráticas
en khan academy todo esto va a ser igual
a cero ahora sí si queremos conocer qué
valores de x hacen que toda esta
expresión sea igual a 0 son los valores
de x que hacen que sí
x sea igual a 0 porque si 5 x 600 x
cualquier cosa va a ser igual a cero qué
valor hace que 5x sea igual a cero pues
si dividimos a ambos lados entre 5 nos
da que x es igual a 0
así que cuando x es igual a 0 todo esto
es 0 y no importa que tengamos aquí al
multiplicarse por 0 todo será igual a 0
y cuál sería el valor de x que hace que
x 3 sea igual a 0 restamos 3 en ambos
lados y queda x igual a menos 3 el otro
valor de x es aquel que hace que x2 sea
igual a 0 sumamos 2 en ambos lados y
queda x igual a 2 y aquí lo tenemos
hemos identificado tres valores de x que
hacen que el polinomio sea igual a cero
estos son los ceros y las intersecciones
en x
tenemos una en x igual a cero tenemos
otra en x igual a menos 3 y tenemos otra
en x igualados con esto respondimos lo
que nos piden aquí
en cana de mí solo tienen que hacer clic
en estos tres puntos pero la razón por
la que esto es útil es porque nos ayuda
a darnos una idea de cómo será la
gráfica del polinomio ya que la gráfica
tiene que interceptar al eje x en estos
puntos
la gráfica puede verse algo así o puede
verse algo así y para saber exactamente
cómo es que luce la gráfica tenemos que
calcular unos cuantos valores más de x
entre estas intersecciones en x para
darnos una idea general de la gráfica